our security and defense editor deborah
haynes is with me now here in keeve and
we were you know watching that speech
for any clues as to possible impact on
the war here did you
see or hear any i think the first thing
to think about is what it should have
been western officials were expecting
that vladimir putin's plan for his war
in ukraine was for this lightning grab
to
to seize the capital here and then to be
able to declare this huge success from
his actions his special operation in
ukraine on victory day may the 9th with
a toppled government here in ukraine a
pro-moscow regime put in place and what
happened the absolute opposite of that
ukrainian forces managed to push the
russian attack out of the north of the
country they're now regrouping in the
east and yes they were waiting to see
whether there would be any signal as to
what might come next and i think the
main conclusion you can draw so far is
that this that russia is doubling down
on its actions they're not going
anywhere yes there was no um new
announcement of a widening of the
offensive of a a greater expansion of
the mobilization of troops but they
already have a significant number of
their ground forces here in ukraine it's
going to require a lot more commitment
by russia to maintain just what they've
got at the moment and so the main
mission the main message really was that
this is a war of attrition now russia's
not going anywhere and for the for
ukraine and for their western allies it
means they too need to be ready to
endure this for the long run and we're
in the center of
uh kiev and it's pretty subdued one has
to say
it is it's very quiet isn't it i mean
there has been a sign of normal life
returning to the streets ever since the
beginning of april really when russian
forces left you've got shops reopening
you've got people coming back to the
capital despite warnings to stay away
but you do still have the air sirens you
do still have airstrikes happening in
fact when president putin was at the red
square parade today an air raid siren
was sounding here in kiev so it's very
much not normal and people do know that
they could come back russia could come
back and try again